maray are you a rule breaker yeah yeah I
could see that dating status in a
relationship okay crazy as sex story
there's been a lot of bathrooms oh okay
are you good friends with your
co-workers yeah yeah but not like good
friends do you like to frequent the
office happy hours yes they're fun okay
good if I said to you sex in the office
where would be a good place to have that
a lot of offices have like like
breastfeeding rooms you usually need
like a little bleep bloop code for it
but if you know that code that would be
a good place food for thought and how
would you get that code I don't know
just being like I have a baby that I
need have a baby over there airtight
okay yeah life short give me one sexual
fantasy I guess office would be cool but
I'm not like an exhibitionist in that
way right have you had sex in an office
no I have not I believe you